which video game adaptations were
originally slated for the silva screen
what award-winning family drama was
almost a movie about octuplets check out
which tv shows were originally planned
to be movies
the gun-slinging bounty hunter from a
galaxy far far away had a tumultuous
journey before finally landing on the
disney streaming service shortly after
disney acquired lucasfilm and by
extension the star wars franchise the
company announced spin-off films telling
stories adjacent to the original star
wars saga boba fett was initially
supposed to be one of those projects
originally josh trank the director of
chronicle and the catastrophic box
office bomb that was 2015's fantastic
four pitched his version of a boba fett
narrative to lucasfilm the studio was
enthusiastic about his ideas and
announced his admission to the star wars
family with tranq set to direct the boba
fett stand-alone production after the
failure and drama that spun out of
fantastic four tranq quit the project
understanding that he'd probably be
fired if he didn't drop out himself
eventually the project landed in the
hands of logan director james mangle but
a certain famous fictional smuggler
seemingly ruined plans for boba fett's
big screen feature
the prequel film solo a star wars story
which chronicled han solo's younger days
picking fights with gangsters and the
empire was considered a financial
disappointment upon its release disney's
focus shifted toward their new streaming
service where the mandalorian became a
flagship series for the service's debut
thanks to that show's success plans for
boba fett's own series quickly followed
and the rest is history
george r.r martin's a song of ice and
fire novels are now as well known as
tolkien's middle earth fantasy thanks to
the additional popularity that the hbo
series game of thrones brought to the
books for years martin had been courted
by scriptwriters who eagerly wanted to
share their version of martin's fantasy
world in live-action cinema like a
king's landing not fit for the dragon
queen's world he scorched these ideas to
ash and cinder according to
entertainment weekly in 2011 martin
claimed that his book series was simply
unfilmable despite visions of the
contrary attempting to sell him on the
idea the author stated even tol king
took three feature films and three told
king novels are as long as one of my
books martin also noted that after
giving a feature film idea some thought
he felt that his works were simply too
mature after all sex and violence
saturate the entire narrative
be quick about it
eventually david binioff and d.b weiss
approached martin and proposed adapting
his books into a series since the show
would land on hbo the mature content was
no longer a problem furthermore benioff
and weiss could take all the time they
needed to build out the story over
several seasons depending on the show's
popularity after reaching in accord with
martin on the direction of the series
film ideas were finally put to rest
the white wolf better known as geralt of
rivia has long been a mainstay of the
fantasy genre andre sapkowski created
the fabled witcher and authored a
collection of stories surrounding his
exploits before riding a sprawling saga
the witcher known for his combat prowess
keen senses and hunting acuity is
capable of slaying the most dangerous of
monsters in the wilds
gralt is often embroiled in the warring
politics evil machinations and drama of
the most prominent characters to
populate the land
netflix was always a prime destination
for the witcher to receive a proper
live-action outing although the
character had appeared in a few
well-received video games made by polish
game developers cd projekt red fans were
chomping at the bit to see geralt
realized in cinematic glory the witcher
was originally going to receive a
standalone netflix film but creatives
behind the scenes convinced the
producers that there was far too much
material to cover in just two hours
convinced that the property deserved
more they got the green light to move
forward with a netflix original series
mr robot was a massive hit for the usa
network centered around a mentally
unwell cybersecurity expert named
elliott the series deals with hacktivism
and political issues of all kinds it
received high praise from both critics
and audiences along the way winning
three emmys two golden globes and a
peabody award i respect that about you
however many likely don't realize that
mr robot was originally intended to be
an independently produced feature film
in an interview with forbes series
creator sam esmail discussed his
creative journey esmel stated when i saw
it as a movie i knew where i was going i
knew the ending the problem was that he
simply had more material than he knew
what to do with as mel continued when i
got to page 90 and i was still halfway
through act one that's when i decided
okay this can be a television show the
showrunner still tackled the series like
a movie production treating each episode
as if it were a short film ultimately
ezmel still achieved what he set out to
do with the narrative he'd originally
planned sure the fiery vigilante of
hell's kitchen already received a big
screen adaptation in 2003 with ben
affleck taking on the role of the blind
lawyer matt murdock however the netflix
daredevil series was also originally
envisioned and pitched as a film by
series creator drew goddard goddard
explained why the film approach
ultimately didn't pan out in an
interview with ign marvel nixed the idea
believing that goddard's approach was
far too dark and violent marvel simply
wouldn't do an r-rated film furthermore
daredevil is typically seen as a local
hero interested primarily in cleaning
the streets of his own neighborhood that
wouldn't gel with the large-scale epics
of the mcu instead daredevil landed on
netflix with goddard free to produce his
far more mature take on the character
goddard who'd previously stated that
anything short of his adult vision would
be inadequate was certainly pleased with
this outcome
believe it or not the sopranos was
originally destined for theaters imagine
seeing james gandolfini's tony soprano
on the silver screen it would have been
a sight to behold however this
hypothetical film wouldn't have been the
cultural landmark that the sopranos
series was across its six seasons
according to series co-creator david
chase the show was conceived as a film
and pitched as such from the get-go
however chase's manager at the time
lloyd braun suggested that his idea
could actually be a television series
chase gave it some thought and began to
wrap his mind around the mobster's life
as an ongoing series the scope of his
pitch changed but only enough to cover
season one ending with tony confronting
his mother over trying to kill him chase
understood this moment as the end of
their tormented relationship and the
second season had to work with fresh
ideas beyond the scope of chase's
original plan in the end of course chase
produced one of the best tv dramas in
history which won 21 emmys and five
golden globes during its time on the air
i'm honored just to be considered the
winding family drama this is us likes to
toy with viewers emotions the story
follows the piercing clan in their three
children who are depicted at various
ages but primarily as adults they
experience many of life's greatest joys
and heartaches after all the pearsons
and many other supporting characters
reflect many facets of american society
while the series has proved to be one of
the most successful dramas in modern
television it wasn't always meant to
depict the same family that we know
today in an interview with emmy magazine
series creator dan fogelman revealed
some juicy details regarding the origins
of the show instead of randall kate and
kevin as the big three fogelman
originally pinned an 80-page film
featuring a pearson family with
octuplets ultimately fogelman decided
that he didn't want to follow a
traditional narrative trajectory with a
beginning middle and end he wanted to
explore a lasting story that
continuously unfolded in the past
present and future of a single family
the character-driven nature of the show
has proved successful engaging audiences
and critics alike let's just be thankful
that we didn't have to follow the
chaotic lives of octuplets
dumb luck
in 2020 the queen's gambit took the
streaming world by storm with a
thrilling period piece based on the 1983
novel by walter tevis the netflix
miniseries centers around beth harmon
portrayed by anya taylor joy as an
orphaned youth she becomes obsessed with
and shows a talent for chess eventually
developing a drug addiction to help her
focus on her game and cope with personal
loss the series chronicles her rise to
fame in the chess world the queen's
gambit novel had long been examined for
a possible feature film adaptation in
fact the late actor heath ledger himself
something of a chess connoisseur was
planning on making his directorial debut
with an adaptation of the novel before
he tragically passed away the project
was halted upon ledger's death and was
eventually pitched to netflix as a
miniseries
fans of the original archie comics
likely never suspected that it would
eventually be adapted for the small
screen in live action the television
series on the cw network titled
riverdale features the exploits of the
famous archie comics teenagers including
archie andrews betty cooper jughead
jones and veronica lodge positioned as a
teen drama riverdale goes big on its
mystery themes and has enjoyed a lasting
legacy on the cw network with its
deliciously dark tones of course archie
almost found himself on the big screen
warner brothers sought an adaptation of
the character on film the creatives
behind the tv series originally had
their idea dismissed and were axed to
work on archie's first ever live-action
appearance in a time traveling story
featuring louis c.k of all people as the
iconic high schooler the studio imagined
a riverdale filled with portals that
would open up to other dimensions that
was just a little too wacky a bit too
much like a live-action rick and morty
thankfully riverdale show creator robert
aguirre sakasa didn't like that idea he
walked away from the whole ordeal only
to be contacted later by the studio to
commit his original vision to television
like the bounty hunting boba fett jedi
master extraordinaire obi-wan kenobi was
once set to return to the big screen in
his own film
after solo a star wars story didn't
exactly gain the financial returns
lucasfilm and disney were looking for
their approach shifted focus the
streaming service disney plush changed
the game for lucasfilm giving ewan
mcgregor a chance to reprise his role on
the streaming platform
hello there in fact both ewan mcgregor
and hayden christensen are set to
reprise their prequel film roles in the
obi-wan kenobi series the show offers
fans the chance to finally see what
obi-wan has been up to for all those
lonesome years in the desert wilderness
of tatooine while his top goal is to
protect luke skywalker it seems that
much more went on behind the scenes that
luke could have ever possibly imagined
as a live-action production the popular
video game property halo has been
through development hell and back aside
from smaller productions like forward
unto dawn and nightfall a true blue halo
film with master chief positioned as the
lead has been in the works as far back
as 2005.
alex garland known for ex-machina and
annihilation was hired by microsoft to
write an adaption of the series for the
silver screen guillermo del toro was
attached to direct but ran for the exit
when he decided to head up hellboy 2 the
golden army
the project eventually bounced over to
district 9 creator neil blomkamp but a
tug of war over creative control between
fox universal and microsoft resulted in
the project being shelved halo once
again entered the live action spotlight
with the announcement of a tv series in
2013 with steven spielberg attached as a
producer news emerged that the series
was being developed for showtime after
going through several producers and
directors the show was shifted to
paramount plus where it made its debut
in march 2022 now halo has received the
renewed attention it deserves in the
live action space although that might be
up for debate among long time fans check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]